Ishta ha Alaska is from Syria and she
knows and trusts DW she's been accessing
the website in her asylum Hospital in
Berlin now she is delighted that she can
watch the Arabic program via Astra
satellite it helps me find my way around
and understand Germany and its laws
Deutsche Welle reports on subjects which
I as a refugee find interesting
DW Arabia broadcasts around the clock in
Arabic it features news broadcasts and a
business magazine focused on German
issues the interactive youth programme
Shabab talk takes on topics including
religion and sexuality subjects which
are taboo in many Arab countries but
millions of people love the show
regardless and it can now be watched
across Europe reliable information and
open debate in the Arabic language
DW wants to play its part in helping
refugees find their way in German
society it is our task to transport
German and European values and so we
have a chance to reach more people and I
think at the long run we will have also
more viewers because people who arrive
now here either they know already our
program and on the other hand I think
they will be convinced that this is a
good program which can help to integrate
here the producers of the Arabic program
are delighted to have the new target
group - Harley Salim is a news anchor
she thinks television for refugees comes
with a lot of responsibility you see
this via the cliche
I need see I can see that we play a
crucial role here in Germany again yeah
and talk we can build a bridge between
people here
so that people can integrate better
loiter here basashi
integral in' Ishta ha Alaska wants even
more practical tips from DW for living
in Germany and that is exactly what the
production team wants to provide to help
refugees get ready for the future in
their new homeland